ein Tag mit Kiki und Hamza an dann ist
das Bayram mein Name nach dem Frühstück
habe ich Last Minute Kinder Geschenke
verpackt hiermit habe ich die Schleifen
schön gelockt oder wie das auch immer
heißt dann haben wir uns ein eiskaramel
Macchiato gegönnt waren im Kikis kitchen
coffee danach sind wir mit der ganzen
Familie palästinen sich essen gegangen
es war eine zehn von zehn sind dann noch
in der Dortmunder Innenstadt spazieren
gegangen am Samstag eine Überraschung
für mich ich bin aus diesem Stuhl nicht
rausgekommen aber egal danach gab es
Entspannung mit Sauna alles schön
ausschwitzen und einfach nur genießen
das war echt ein schöner Tagesabschluss